logan webb making start number 16 5-3 on
the year webb his second year at the big
league level
this is a lead-off walk to connor joe
lots of power now bryant over the second
there's one back to first two a double
play
great turn with a lot of pressure from
connor joe there by brandon crawford
he got him to chase the slider in the
dirt because sally tags him out ends up
being a strong inning
they'll take ederman for the win here
because of the way he's been pitching
lately i mentioned it in his last 14
ball games eight and four but just a 236
2-2 pitch
did he go they appealed down to third
and yes says doug eddings he did follow
through on that swing and that's an
opening strikeout for airmon marcus
left center field into the gap racing
after it now
and up into the seats
hilliard
with a
valiant effort to get it
made delete ended up in a heap right at
the base of the wall connor joe helped
him up a double for la stella
and that ball's left up
and
herman knows he's fortunate this will be
uh
a fly ball to the left the one two and a
good fastball at 97. so hermione gives
up a one-out double comes back and ends
up with a couple of punch-outs here's
brandon crawford to start the second
inning for the giants
well that's a great pitch carbon has
struck out three already now into his
motion swing and a miss on the breaking
ball and that's strike three back to
back to back strikeouts were too quickly
gone the hot-hitting backup catcher kurt
casalli
and he draws the walk
to sally at second two down we'll get
alex dickerson to the plate
right center field
no
not quite for blackman
a run is in casalli scores and alex
dickerson continues with that history of
success
against marquez
and dickerson gives an idea how strong
his hands are
he didn't get all of his lower body into
it but he finds a gap
here is dom nunez the lead off against
logan webb who's got a one-nothing lead
now
right there strikes recall
o2
is called strike three with the slider
that was a beauty
right there outside corner ending over
he strikes out the side
bring up trevor story o2 pitch and that
hit him
came in and got him on the left arm or
hand trevor spins out of there and walks
down the third base line and he's going
to regroup for a moment yeah
actually hit the guard and then hit his
forearm
down close to his wrist the rockies will
get a base runner now as
trevor seems to check out okay a little
bit sore no doubt so charlie blackman
the hitter rocky's down one to nothing
three two he goes blackman lights one
it's caught and it's gonna be a double
play
giants catch a break right to tommy la
stella one pitch two outs here now is
brandon crawford with one out in the
fourth crawford out into left center
field that's another hit for brandon
crawford hilliard coming over to cut it
off brandon's gonna stop hilliard has a
good arm and he threw it back into
second so crawford settles for the one
out single
yostramski goes the opposite way
hillyard again sprints over to scoop it
up back to back singles by the giants
two on one out bring up the catcher
cassalli
pulled sharply fair pass the dive of
mcmahon
down the left field line crawford will
score yoshremski to third and cassalli
into second with a double
two nothing giants
and another great plate appearance for
kurt casalli
breaks it and mcmahon never had a chance
alex dickerson in his 391 lifetime
batting average against the rockies
already with a double in this game so
they put him at first load the bases up
only one out for the pitcher logan webb
webb to center field and deep
really deep off the wall
yastrebski and casalli are both going to
score
he was a couple of feet away from a
grand slam
and he gets a two-run single
it's four-nothing he gets a fastball out
over the plate at 94.
and he puts a charge into it that winds
up
about our 390 foot single and look how
close it was to going over the wall
being right there at the top and
hilliard had no chance
four nothing giants still only one out
wade
may have done even better he just
demolished that it's gone
up over the 20-foot wall out in deep
right center field
and now the giants are putting it on
marquez seven nothing
that thing was obliterated
we're talking total t-ball location
middle of the plate middle of the thigh
and lamont way junior put a dent in it
hilliard who walked his first time up
kind of looking back door slider perfect
location the o2 pitch
in there strike three called
outside corner got him looking
seven strikeouts and a shutdown inning
three up and three down for webb
3-2 to counter joe is a bouncer towards
first bell grabs it but logan webb got
caught watching and got to the bag late
and it's an infield hit for connor joe
he'll hit this one to left field coming
on yostremski or dickerson excuse me he
traps the ball
and it'll be a base hit for ryan mcmahon
two on two out trevor story a chance
struck him out with the slider
nicely done logan webb a little
weirdness there in the six but he gets
through it giant seven rockies nothing
and the giants bring in a new pitcher
it's the right-hander jay jackson out of
the bullpen so logan webb goes six
pitched extremely well
that is drilled into deep center
and caught by yaz there was no question
about it one away here is cj crone he
struck him out
struck him out
three up three down a couple of
strikeouts
hitting number nine one last chance for
the rockies dovah stays in
fastball under the hands the new left
fielder is lamont way junior one away
and slider
punched to le stella
struck him out the giants win their
fifth in a row and linkedin their lead
in the national league west to five
games over the dodgers